[Music]
welcome back to our fifth annual
Halloween special my favorite time of
year the best time of year Halloween
this year we're talking all about scary
films for the entire month of October if
you haven't been seeing my earlier
videos and now we're gonna be talking
about a Friday the 13th movie and this
is the perfect day to release this video
Friday the 13th part 6 Jason lives let
me tell you a little bit about my
history with this franchise I understand
the popularity of the Halloween films
because the first one is a legitimate
classic the second one is even pretty
good stay tuned for this Halloween I
might be talking about that but when it
comes to the Friday the 13th movies I
don't really consider the first one to
be that great of a film it's basically a
slasher movie with Jason and he kills
people but it takes itself very
seriously it's not tongue-in-cheek in
the slightest and it was clearly trying
to profit off of the new trend of
slasher movies started by Halloween in
78 it took them all the way to part 6 to
finally realize what I think this
franchise needs some fun some levity not
to take itself too seriously this is a
guy in a hockey mask who runs around
killing people at camps that rarely ever
have children in fact part six is the
only summer camp in the entire franchise
that actually has real children staying
there so they even got that right in the
beginning of Jason lives Tommy Jarvis
visits Jason's grave and tries to put an
end to him once and for all because I
guess being integrate and dead
underground isn't good enough for this
guy he stabs the corpse over and over
again with a metal rod and eventually
lightning strikes this rod and
resurrects Jason and makes him a
super-powered zombie and it's fucking
awesome part 6 has my favorite kills in
the franchise it's the most fast-paced
it doesn't take itself seriously it's
actually fairly well directed it has
good suspenseful sequences and a great
amount of atmosphere and it finally
understands that the only merit this
franchise really has is us waiting to
see Jason kill somebody and the tension
that comes before that kill they don't
try to set up real characters they just
want to have
fun I mean after Jason gets resurrected
by a bolt of lightning the first kill is
him punching through someone's chest and
removing the heart on the other side it
does not get better than that or does it
because immediately after that we get a
James Bond style opening starring Jason
[Music]
this is exactly what the franchise
needed at the time someone to come in
and just make a really entertaining
horror film that didn't take itself
seriously that recognize that it
probably shouldn't have from the very
beginning because it was never gonna be
as good as Halloween no matter how many
times they tried so let's just try to
make something fun and they nailed it
the film is extremely self-aware even
the characters directly reference that
they're in a horror movie to the
audience sometimes even breaking the
fourth wall Darrin we better turn around
because I've seen enough horror movies
to know any weirdo wearing a mask is
never friendly pick up Jason some folks
have a strange idea entertainment now I
can see how some might not like this
some people really do like the first few
Friday the 13th movies and find them
very entertaining I think they're
perfectly watchable movies that you can
watch around October and not really care
about seeing but whenever you actually
sit down and try to invest yourself in
the Friday the 13th movies for myself
anyway it's kind of hard but this one
for whatever reason just knows exactly
what it has to be I mean Jason murders a
misogynistic paintball player the movie
has a lot of physical comedy as well
sometimes even involving Jason
he'll kill someone and then be surprised
by this strength that he showed there's
a scene with one of the paintball
players tripping over a lot of branches
over and over when Jason pulls a girl
out of a window her slippers fly off
part six also features some of the most
trigger-happy policemen that I've ever
seen in a film the sheriff for this
movie is an idiot
one of the biggest character
confrontations in fact really the only
character confrontation in the movie is
because Tommy is trying to tell the
sheriff that Jason is back and the
sheriff doesn't want anything to do with
that he keeps locking him up and he
denies it for the entire film until
Jason is face to face with the sheriff
but they are both so incredibly
testosterone-fueled
that they cannot see past anything
especially the one guy who has a new
laser sight he really is itching to
kill people with it body parts actually
start showing up dismembered body parts
and they still don't believe Tommy
seeing that Jason's back he actually
thinks that Tommy is the one setting me
setting the legs around for them to find
I'm like dude come on you're just stupid
how are you sheriff right now it's all
so dumb that they try to make a central
romance out of the sheriff's daughter
she sees Tommy in jail in the opening
and is like all of a sudden into him and
they just want to be together you don't
care for a second but the film
constantly asks you to it's one of the
biggest downfalls of this movie and I
feel like I should reiterate this is
obviously not a great film but if you go
into Friday the 13th part six knowing
that it's a tongue-in-cheek hilariously
exciting Jason movie where they finally
just honed it down no filler all killer
as Stephen King has said in the past
about certain things that's what this
film is and that's why I like it and
it's my favorite of the franchise this
film has the best kills in the entire
franchise there's a couple pretty good
ones in Jason X which is probably my
least favorite of all of them the ice
one and that was pretty good but there's
just so much here I mean a paintball
scene for God's sakes there's a
paintball seen this movie I love it it
does have one of my biggest gripes in
film though I hate when people run out
of a car and leave their door open it's
like why like if you need to escape you
could kill your battery why would you
not just close your door so many people
do that in movies and it's a big gripe
of mine most people probably don't give
a shit I care
close your fucking doors in movies
people Jason is so super powered in part
six that he does not need the luxury of
door knobs he will go through the wall
if he needs to one of the downfalls of
this movie being so fast-paced is that
they basically just throw away the lore
of how Tommy discovers how to kill Jason
apparently he finds some occult books in
a car and he reads them real fast and he
knows that he has to kill Jason that
Camp Crystal Lake and drown him where he
was originally killed I'm like what
whatever set the lake on fire
it'll look
cool right so after the big showdown
where Jason twists a girl's head off and
scares a bunch of children and blood
ease up an entire room eventually they
fight on a boat and Jason gets drowned
under water and then royally fucked by a
boat propeller and it's awesome and of
course there's a stupid final shot where
his eye opens up and is clearly not
underwater as well which is even dumber
part six is a major guilty pleasure for
me I'm obviously not saying this is a
great film it's very cheesy the
characters are hollow it's dumb I mean
he gets resurrected by a bolt of
lightning but it has a James Bond style
opening and characters directly
referenced there in a horror movie to
the screen this is the first in the
franchise that was a comedy but it knew
it and it knew how to do it properly it
didn't disrespect fans of Jason it gave
fans of Jason what they wanted but also
for myself not a big fan of the
franchise this is the one that I can
watch and be like okay
they get it what do you think I think
we're dead meat
[Music]
if you're not a big fan of the Friday
the 13th movies check this one out
it might convert you it's really dumb
but it's a blast thank you for
continuing to watch our fifth annual
Halloween special we have a lot more
coming for you guys very soon and happy
Friday the 13th day as always if you
like this you can click right here and
get stuck mine eyes
[Music]